μει ευγεήκαμέ για τογια τααρκωτικά βγαίνουμε με ολοκληρωμένες προτάσης οποίος μπορεί να έχουν πέντε αξωνες
πολιτικής μια στρατιγική ένα ώραμα μια στρατιγική πεντάξιως πολιτικής και από κεί και πέρα τριάντα
πολιτικές λύσεις προτάσεις τούτες οι οιτούτε των περίσουμαρ μας όσον αφορατί πιότητα τις παραγόμενης δουλειάς
έχουμε και πέεπου με αρποσότητας και εμείς μεχρι σήμερα στς καστις στις κιακός ες μέρες
πουδουλεύκουμε στω δημοκραι αγερμώ των συμβούλιών έχουμε παράξεκατόνικωσι πρωτάσεις να μου ποίες ειδαμετε ναι είδεδεδες
αλλά εελάβαν την αναγκαα δημοσιότητα πορεί όχι ίδι ότι οη πρωταάσεις οι ολιστικές συνολικές για
να θεμα και σημαίνει ότιοι προσ λαμβάνον την ήδια πό τον θέμα τα θεμα τολογιακριβώς
να χρησιμοποιηθούν όμως σε μεταγενές τεροχρόνων μια ώρα πορ να αυκή ένα θέμα ται σε
δημοπολησιουμό οποιοίσιαμε και οι στόχευση μας εμάς σε επίπεδο πωσότητας πιότητας είπαμε πωσότητας ιστοχέσης νας
είαιναι μια πρόταση την μέρα εμείς αυτή τη στιμή είμαστε στηείναι ακομματέσθρα προτάση την ημέρα
μετρώτην ώρα μεπιστεύου μετά το καλοκέρι θα είμαστε στη μία πρόταση την ημέρα αποπλευράς παραγωγικότητας
αποπληγάς πιότητας να το δούμε να κριθούν οι προτάσεις μα στην ώρα που της λέμε
και τα λοιπά κοινμε πιο υποκιμενικώ αλλά έσ και αντικοιμενικά πράγματα με αυτό των τρόπο
μετρούμε την παραγωγή μας σαν σμβούλειω μετρούμε και την πιότητα μας σαν συμβούλειω και πάμε
παρακάτωκαι η επόμενοι ρώτηση τα που ταν ακριβώς σερα πέτε πράγματα μάλιστα α οποίας λοιπόν
αυτή τη στιγμή μιώθω ότι ένα μεγάλον πρόβλημα της κυβέρνησης είναι αυτό που λέμε από
την αρχή που είναι οι παροχές οριζόντια